well thanks to everybody for coming I'm
very happy to be here and what I thought
I'd do is I start with this now I've
been speaking at a medical school
obviously I would assume most of you
know what this is but what I find
interesting is that even if we were
outside of a medical school most people
would know what this is they would
recognize a brain they know what a brain
looks like everyone does and yet how
many people outside of a medical school
have actually seen a real brain actually
held one in their hands while I was
working on sold my flesh I went up to
the Columbia Medical School to
participate in one of their brain
cuttings because I wanted to actually
have that feeling and it's quite intense
but I didn't need that experience of
holding a real brain in my hand to know
what a brain is there's something kind
of strange about this because I mean no
one ever sees a brain in their real life
and and not only do we all know what
this is but we sort of all agree on what
it represents what we're looking at is a
collection of cells these neurons that
are forming networks and trading signals
and out of that exchange emerges our
emotions and our thoughts perceptions
and our actions who we are is contained
in in the flesh of the brain we are
quite familiar in medical schools and
outside of them with images like this
one where scientists will be scanning
mental activity and being able to locate
the parts of the brain that form these
networks to do all of these incredibly
abstract things like for example
mathematics or memory now the funny
thing is that this is while this all
seems kind of obvious to us
in the history of Western thought it's
really new and for a long time it was
not obvious at all and to really give
you a sense of what I'm talking about I
want to show you this quote from the
philosopher Henry Moore now Henry Moore
in the 17th century you probably
couldn't find a greater philosopher in
terms of just pure brilliance maybe
Descartes babylock that's about it and
in 1652 he declared very categorically
that referring to the brain this lacks
pith or marrow in the man's head shows
no more capacity for thought than a cake
of suet or bowl of curds so how is it
that he could say something like this
how could he hold the brain in such
contempt well one reason is is really
quite simple you know if like like us he
would rarely see a real brain and if
anyone were to try to look at a brain in
1652 say in a cadaver the thing would
have become been so decayed and such a
mess that really literally what you
would be looking at would be a bowl of
curds it would hardly be the stuff for
for carrying out what would then be
called the work of the soul but also
Henry Moore is standing at the end of a
very long tradition of thousands of
years of Western thought that put what
we would call the life of the mind in a
totally different world in a completely
different different explanations that
are very hard for us to understand today
it's fascinating to understand how
people would think in this different way
what I think is even more fascinating is
that Henry Moore says this in 1652 20
years later no one would say this 20
years later everyone has agreed on the
basics of what the brain means they
would agree with us about what the brain
is what the brain represents there was
this incredible switch that
and this switch actually I think has a
lot to tell us about what I think is a
second revolution going on in
neuroscience today so if you are a 17th
century thinker in Europe you have a
couple different major sources that are
really dominating the way you're
thinking about what we would call the
life of the mind there is of course the
Bible everything that you talk about in
terms of the way people are in terms of
human nature is going to have to square
one way or another with the Bible now
the Bible is obviously not a neurology
textbook what it really talks about is
is the soul particularly in the New
Testament saying that we have this this
immortal soul that will be you know
saved or face damnation in the afterlife
now it's not entirely clear in the Bible
sort of how that soul connects to our
bodies to the to the world at large if
you will there are but there are some
interesting ways in which there's this
connection so for example from the Bible
there is a long tradition of considering
epilepsy where we consider a
neurological disorder to be positioned
by demons or by spirits so Jesus is in a
sense sort of a neurologist at its time
because he's believed to be able to cure
epilepsy by ridding a person of their
demons this is a 13th century painting
of just this event people believe that
that people called epilepsy and seizures
because they really believed that there
was something some force that was
seizing a person and shaking them around
and so you had to get that force out of
that person's body now to get more of a
detailed understanding of these things
a European thinker like a physicist or a
natural philosopher say or even a
theologian would go back to the Greeks
now Greek thought was it was incredibly
powerful throughout the Middle Ages the
Renaissance and into the 17th century
for some really astonishing reasons one
is that one is that people believed that
the earth was just a few thousand years
old and so what this meant was that
people who lived in ancient Greece or
Rome were living very close to the time
of creation and Adam had perfect
knowledge and so the Greeks because
there was so much closer to Adam had
knowledge and an understanding that was
so far superior to our own so that there
was no point in thinking of before
yourself because Aristotle and Galen of
the Roman physician they were all there
before you so what you had to do is you
had to go back into these books which
are being translated from from Arabic
and being sort of put together into
Latin translations that people could
actually read in Europe and try to piece
together what they knew now what they
knew what they thought they knew was
that the body was made of four humors
these humors are fluids there are
different combinations of the four
elements so you've got black bile yellow
bile blood which is not what we think of
when we say blood and phlegm these are
the these are the four things that
dominate a person and they don't only
dominate your body but they dominate
your your temperament your personality
so for example if a person is just
naturally has a lot of black bile in
Latin melancholy their melancholy and if
you have an imbalance of this if you
have too much melancholy in your system
you might become extremely depressed or
stark raving mad so you had to keep
people's humors in in the proper balance
now of course for a doctor in the Middle
Ages you know what they would do they
would basically you know take blood out
of people bloodletting was basically the
cure for everything but they had these
very elaborate explanations about how
bloodletting would help to bring humors
into balance this is a diagram from from
the Middle Ages
with illustrations from the Middle Ages
showing the the different kind of
personalities so The Melancholy person
is in bed very sad and and melancholy
now this was very powerful for many
reasons and one of them is that to be
part to be made up of four humors linked
you to the cosmos there was there was no
kind of dividing line between your body
and yourself and and the cosmos because
the four humors were the made of these
four elements and not only that but
different constellations were believed
to be connected to different humors and
because different organs had different
humors in them you would look to
different constellations to understand
what was going on and for example in the
head or in the liver or so on and that's
why doctors would was very important to
cast a horoscope in order to treat
someone and there were a lot of thinkers
who took this even and further and they
kind of followed up on some ideas of
Plato and they would say that we are
actually a miniature version of the
cosmos as a whole we are a microcosm of
the macrocosm so in a sense this is a
very comforting idea
it's very resilient this is an idea that
can last for centuries and it did very
well
now the the cosmos actually was believed
to have a soul and and we were all
believed to have soul but we tend to
just talk about the soul see
Giller when we talk about people's souls
in the Middle Ages in the Renaissance it
was a belief that people had three souls
the most important was the the rational
immortal soul which was or the business
of the church but there was also a
mortar Soul in the liver
now this soul was believed to produce
blood it was also believed to produce
our appetites and our desires in
addition the heart was believed to have
a soul of its own and this soul this
vital soul gave the body its life
supporting warmth it sent out what we
call vital spirits to do its bidding to
keep to keep the body warm and alive and
not only that but it produced passion
and produced action he was even believed
to have some powers of perception our
silent even believed that that the heart
was completely responsible for sensation
and action and so in the Middle Ages
when people taught Anatomy they what
they were really doing was they were
demonstrating how the body was arranged
for these three souls this wasn't really
what we would call scientific this was a
really a religious kind of demonstration
that was being done this is a picture of
how Anatomy was typically done you'd
have a cadaver usually have an executed
criminal and then a surgeon would be
cutting it open and the anatomist is up
in a chair reading from Galen and
telling you what's in there the
anatomist would never dare to go down
and actually look for himself because
what was the point
Galen knew everything already could
explain everything his knowledge was
perfect so he would simply use galen's
Anatomy to explain how the body was was
arranged for these three souls now as
weird as this is for us to think about
it really left a very deep impression on
Western thought so for example
we talked about being heartbroken or
knowing something in our heart this all
comes from this this soul in the heart
this vital soul and it influenced
Christianity as well so there you have
the the phenomenon of the Sacred Heart
it's very interesting and very telling
that that when Jesus is is revealing
himself in these sorts of images he's
not showing us his brain he's showing us
his heart now it wasn't that people
weren't interested in the head
it's just that they weren't interested
in the brain so here's a diagram from
1504 what really mattered we're what we
believed to be these three giant
spherical holes in your head these were
called ventricles we do have little
spaces in our head they don't look
anything like three three circular
spherical holes but people were
convinced that they were there and what
they believed was that the vital spirits
of the heart would mix with air and then
go into the head and become what we call
animal spirits and they would swirl
through these holes these ventricles and
they would produce a memory or
imagination and then they would go into
the rest of the body now as you can see
what we know to really matter the brain
is just the background in this picture
it's just those little sort of squiggles
in this picture it's considered
completely unimportant and it was
believed that that whatever it was doing
its only purpose was to keep these holes
enlarged in life of course when people
would cut open a brain after life they
would see that see this kind of funny to
form little holes but they said well
that's because the person is dead though
they're not being sort of held taut and
open the way we know that they are so
just to give you an idea of how powerful
an idea this was you consider the case
of Leonardo da Vinci now here's one of
the greatest thinkers of all time and
also a great anatomist
he does wonderful drawings himself of
all sorts of anatomical details now when
he drew the the head this is what he
drew and as you can see you have this
big empty space and then these sort of
very kind of schematic holes that are
supposed to be connected in a chain so
you got to give Leonardo Divinci credit
he said to himself okay I want to really
understand what these ventricles are
like so what he did was he took some hot
wax and he injected it in the brain of a
dead ox freshly killed and the wax
hardened and then he cut open the head
and what looked to see what it looked
like and where it was situated and how
it connected to the nerves and for
example for example he got a total mess
when he opened up the Oxus head these
these holes were just in all sorts of
crazy directions and he he was good
enough of a scientist to say alright I'm
going to draw it the way I see it but
then I'm going to try to connect them
and connect them to the nerves because I
know that they're connected I know that
these ventricles are wouldn't matter
here so so even Leonardo da Vinci was
still prey to these ideas now things
started to change a bit in the mid 1500s
thanks in large part to the great
anonymous Andreas Vesalius what he did
was he was actually looking at bodies on
his own and realized that Galen had been
had made all these descriptions based on
oxen or monkeys or all these animals and
no one had bothered to realize that he
had never looked at a human ever you
know maybe he had looked at them when he
was you know tending to a wound but that
was it so Vesalius drew a new anatomy
with these spectacular pictures and
really sort of made Anatomy a science
the way we think of it in the terms of
you know of something that you could
discover something new about
now Vesalius also looked at the brain
what he did was the kind of crude to say
the least he would cut off the top layer
of brain and look down see what was
there and then he cut off another layer
and looked down and see what was there
he wasn't doing this in a nice
refrigerated room or anything he didn't
have any preservatives so it got to be
quite a mess by the time he was done but
he still did a very good job considering
and you know he was really struck by how
the ventricles did not conform to what
the church said they did and he brought
up the subject and he said maybe we
should be thinking differently about the
head and maybe about the brain but then
he stopped and he literally said that he
did not want to be taken for a heretic
he did not want to get into trouble so
the things are stood like that until
there was a kind of a fresh shock to the
system as it were and it came from a
surprising place it came from the cosmos
it used to be believed that that the
earth was at the center of the universe
of the cosmos and Aristotle gave very
good explanations for why I mean because
for example if you picked up a rock a
rock is made of the element earth and
the element earth has a natural motion
to go to the center of the cosmos so
that's why when you pick it up and you
drop it it falls back down so this
wasn't just astronomy this was physics
this was just a whole way of thinking
about about the world at large now in
the same year that Vesalius publishes
his Anatomy Copernicus publishes his
book saying that no the Sun is at the
center and the earth was just another
planet this doesn't just throw astronomy
into question it also brings physics
itself into question it wasn't until the
early 1600s when Galileo really started
to to think carefully about these two
implications and try to bring them
together
and so his famous studies with the
telescope were along these lines
he was look up in the sky and he would
see that the moon was not a perfect orb
it was just a it was a battered rock
made out of the same kinds of materials
that are made here on earth and so
whatever laws are governing governing
its movements are also governing
governing movements on earth so he
started to try to think of a new kind of
physics physics made of forces and to
take Aristotle's place so there's a
natural implication what about the body
what if instead of these these
mysterious souls and their mysterious
spirits what if we are dealing with just
a system of levers for example with with
machines this is what becomes called the
mechanical philosophy it's not about
building cars it's about trying to
explain the world and ourselves with
physics now Rene Descartes the French
philosopher takes this the next level he
is trying to come up with a whole system
of physics to explain the world and and
he's not going to stop at the body he's
gonna go right into the body as well and
he says that you know we really do not
need to be talking about these these
souls in the heart or in the liver we're
just gonna do without them we don't need
to because everything that the body does
can be explained just through the
movement of particles sort of bumping
into each other and and producing these
different actions so for example when
you look at something it's not that your
soul is is receiving the form of an
arrow for example it's just the physics
of it all it's the geometry of your eyes
and the way that the light bounces off
of the of the arrow and goes into your
brain now you'll see that little serve
teardrops sort of space there
I'll get back to that in a second this
is this is where things get a little
funky with Descartes you see it here
again the sort of teardrop shaped space
this illustration is showing how you
could have a reflex movement without any
need for a soul so why is it that we
pull away from a fire is it because some
sort of soul perceives that there's a
fire and and produces this movement no
he says it would just be this automatic
system in which the particles of the
fire would press against the nerve in
your foot and then pull on the nerve and
the nerve would be would start be like a
bell rope and it would open up a hole in
the ventricles and then that would let
spirits flow down through the ventricles
and down to the nerve and then they
would swell up the foot and create a
muscular contraction it's obviously a
bit crazy to describe but it's quite
brilliant and it really is the first way
of thinking about involuntary movements
now what about that funny teardrop up
there that was basically the ventricles
and Descartes believed that the the
rational soul was located in a tiny
little thing the pineal gland which he
thought was located just above the vent
of the ventricles so that even though
the rational soul was immaterial it
could sort of jostle around and sort of
shunt this this animal spirits in
different directions and and that would
be able to produce voluntary movements
unfortunately the de cartes Anatomy was
really wasn't there to back him up he
really took great pride in his Anatomy
he when people would say would ask to
see his library he would take him into a
room where he would have a calf that it
was he had half dissected just lying
there on the table and he would say
these are my books
unfortunately he wasn't reading those
books very well I mean this is his
drawing of a sheep brain I mean we're
not talking about Vesalius here
and that sort of kept Descartes from
really kind of launching what we would
call a real science at the brain of what
we call neurology it was this man who
would do it Thomas Willis is the person
who coined the word neurology who wrote
the first major book on the brain and
the nerves and who established a lot of
our basic understanding of how the brain
works most people haven't heard of him
you may have heard of him because of a
set of blood vessels that were named
after him called the Circle of Willis
but other than that he's unfortunately
one of the Forgotten heroes of science
hi um I talked a lot about Thomas
Wallace in the book he was born in 1621
outside of Oxford
his parents were were were poor and he
was able to get into Oxford well on what
we would basically call scholarship he
would make meals for a professor clean
up after him he also worked as an
apprentice to the professor's wife who
was sort of a an amateur doctors making
various drugs for people who were sick
in the neighborhood he was very loyal to
the Church of England and to the king
and so when Puritans and Parliament rose
up against the king he took up arms to
defend King Charles at first and Oxford
actually became Charles's headquarters
and became besieged by Parliament Oliver
Cromwell would would sort of stand in
the hills and be trying to figure out
how to crush the army there in Oxford
and Thomas Willis was up on the walls
defending his king and his church from
from from these from these onslaughts
while he was there William Harvey was
there as well and William Harvey would
have a huge influence on him Harvey of
course showed that the that blood
circulates around the body which
and through as pumped by the heart which
was an incredibly radical idea at the
time and what was even more radical was
that he figured this out and
demonstrated it with experiments so this
is an experiment where he binds
someone's arm and then kind of moves the
blood and their blood vessels to show
the direction in which the blood is
pumping through the arteries and the
veins so Thomas Willis takes from him
this idea of of anatomy and physiology
being these experimental sciences things
where you can actually do something
yourself what's also very important to
consider is that he was an alchemist
alchemy is sort of has a bad reputation
these days a sort of being on the losing
side of scientific history but really
before modern chemistry got started
alchemy was about as close to what we
would call science as you'd find and in
some cases alchemists were quite
rigorous and they made some really
important discoveries Willis would spend
a lot of time in sort of a his his own
personal laboratory trying to make
different explosive compounds things
other than gunpowder because gunpowder
was very valuable and we wanted to find
a new new way to to you know be able to
launch cannons or bullets or so on but
he also was interested in alchemy as a
doctor medical alchemy was a really
important tradition how could you make
drugs that could transform the body in
the same way the Philosopher's Stone was
supposed to transform lead into gold
the important thing out of all is is
it's all out of all of this is that
Thomas Willis starting of the body
chemically Descartes tended to think of
it as just all these particles started
knocking into each other but Thomas
Willis was interested in the
transformations the chemical
transformations what he would call the
ferments that happened in the body and
he would think about them in terms of
the brain later on
the the the King of course lost the
Civil War and got his head cut off and
people like Thomas Willis became
outcasts so Thomas Willis worked as a as
a doctor in Oxford but had almost no
clientele at all for some years and he
all of the old supporters of the King at
the University were thrown out and lots
of Puritans and other people were
brought in Thomas Willis was sort of a
quiet rebel he hosted a church in his
own house
where people could carry out the rites
of the Church of England which was
totally illegal at the time what's
important here is that you know for for
what I would argue is the first
neurologist religion was central it was
paramount for him and you can't sort of
divide him into sort of science and
religion in the 1600s that would be
meaningless now what was interesting
about the years after the Civil War was
that all sorts of interesting people
came to Oxford because of all this
upheaval and a lot of them were very
much influenced by Francis Bacon the
thinker who had had he really was the
first sort of British thinker who had
argued for what we would think of as a
scientific culture of national
institutions like museums and hospitals
and so on and he thought of a sort of a
utopia were scientists would be able to
test hypotheses and and discover new
knowledge and you know infinite wealth
would be discovered and an infinite
health as well
so among the people who came were just
an astonishing group so Christopher Wren
came as a young student we think of him
as an art as an architect but at the
time he was just an extraordinary
prodigy doing all sorts of things he
would build new kinds of telescopes he
developed new kinds of microscopes and
he and Robert Hooke would make these
beautiful drawings for example the Flies
had things that people had never really
seen before and they would make the in
our
that this was a very good argument in
favor of of life being composed of atoms
not of Aristotle's four elements but of
atoms different kinds of atoms perhaps
but you know if a fly's head is so
intricately designed then surely God
must be using atoms to do it this was
the kind of language that they would use
another person that Thomas Willis got to
know was Robert Boyle pretty much the
one of the founders of modern chemistry
and he was trying to turn alchemy into a
real science and at the time he was
experimenting with vacuum pumps for
example and showing all sorts of strange
things like for example if you put a
candle in a pump and then pumped all the
air out the candle with mysteriously go
out how would you explain that so you
have all sorts of incredible things
going on at the time and out of all of
this Thomas Willis would invent the
science of Neurology how this happened
was that in 1660 king charles ii was
restored to the throne and everyone who
had defended his father was now redeemed
so Thomas Willis was immediately made a
professor at Oxford the Puritan who had
had the job before was fired
opened up a space and he took over now
he was supposed to go back to teaching
Aristotle and all the nice old stuff
that had been Osprey much set in stone
before all the chaos of the civil war
broke out but he wasn't interested at
all he would teach all of his new ideas
that he had and he did something more he
decided that this was an opportunity for
him to do something that he said was
mapping the anatomy of the soul so why
did Thomas Willis do this it's partly
medical and it's partly religious Willis
was a had seen hundreds and thousands of
patients and had seen a lot of cases of
what we would call neurological or
psychiatric disorders he would see
people who were hysterical he would see
people he said we're convinced that
their bodies were made of glass or
convinced that they were wolves people
he's either he wrote about who fell
asleep with food in their mouths and he
was he was this wonderfully gifted
observer he really gives some of the
first descriptions of say narcolepsy
falling asleep with your food in your
mouth or migraine wonderful descriptions
of migraine headaches and all sorts of
other things and he wanted to cure these
disorders not just to sort of alleviate
the pain that people were suffering but
to save their souls
because according to his religious
outlook you you were it was possible for
you to achieve salvation through good
acts in this life but you had to be
rational about it you had to know what
you were doing so if some sort of
disease was clouding your reasoning then
your soul might not be saved now Will's
also knew that all of the conventional
medicine that he had been taught was all
wrong and he was very excited by all of
these ideas that the Scientific
Revolution was bringing out so so he
took Harvey's kind of experiments he
took the atoms of alchemy
he used the new instruments like the
microscopes that Christopher Wren was
using and he started dissecting brains
because he's thought you know I think
that brains need a second look this is
from the cover of his book that he wrote
about the experience it's called the
anatomy of the brain and nerves and it
was the first book written about the
brain just about the brain and in the
nervous system the the cadaver that you
would see there it might not necessarily
be some executed criminal because Thomas
Willis could do something that previous
anatomist couldn't he would dissect his
patients after they died and he would
actually be interested to try to figure
out if he could find anything in their
bodies and in their brains in particular
that he could link with some disease
that they had suffered so for example
hysteria was literally believed to
be the womb moving up in the body and as
a young doctor Thomas Willis had
believed this but then he started
dissecting people and finding that women
who had been hysterical had completely
normal uterus and so that and other
reasons made him think that no it's not
this old explanation of the womb moving
we have to look somewhere else we have
to look in the brain is where he said so
he was also able to preserve brains by
putting them in alcohol and injecting
them with dyes Christopher Wren had
invented this syringes for for making
injections and so he was able to see
brains and away no one had seen before
and this is actually Christopher Wren's
illustration that was in his book mr.
Christopher Wren among other things was
a great medical illustrator so here you
have this gorgeous illustration that's
so far beyond anything that had come
before and Thomas Wells is able to trace
out all the structures of the brain and
able to see how incredibly complex it is
not just on the outside but on the
inside so he sees all sorts of hidden
structures as well and so what he
decides is that you know these
ventricles just don't matter even does
experiments where he injects dyes into
the ventricles to see where I go they
don't really go anywhere and so he looks
at the brain itself he argues that it's
the brain itself where we need to look
for for the business of the soul now
what Willis argued was that while we
still have this immaterial immortal soul
we also have what he called the
sensitive soul which does a huge amount
of stuff and and when you read well as
talking about the sensitive soul you
almost start to wonder well what's the
rational soul therefore what do you need
it for it because the sensitive soul
which is the brain and the nervous
system can do so much and Willis talks
about the spirits moving around
different parts of the brain to do
different things if some parts of the
brain are responsible for involuntary
movement
he says and summer for voluntary
movements all these ideas that we sort
of take for granted now but this was all
completely new and Thomas Willis also
dissected lots of animals detected
lobsters and oysters he detected sheep
he's dissected dogs lots of dogs and he
could see lots of similarities between
the nerves and animals and humans and it
was really astonished to see that
monkeys had brains that were very hard
to distinguish from humans and he being
a good scientist said this means that
their sensitive soul is a lot like ours
the more that their brains like ours the
more they are like us now obviously we
look at it from the point of view of
evolution now that these are all the
products of common ancestry monkeys have
a very recent common ancestor with us
compared to lobsters for example now
Willis wouldn't go that far but he was
sort of laying the groundwork there this
- - he was still quite revolutionary
even in his own time and to get a sense
of it I just wanted to show this this
wonderful picture
this shows the sympathetic nervous
system the the sympathetic nervous
system connects to all of the organs of
the heart and stomach for example and is
its you can sort of think of it as being
producing what you would call your gut
feeling among other things it's these
sort of mysterious ways in which your
stomach could turn or your heart would
race or your face would become flushed
in the 1500s in the Renaissance people
would talk about it as a sort of a
sympathy between different organs and
between the organs and the rest of the
cosmos that there was this interplay
going on a very mystical kind and that's
where the term the sympathetic nervous
system comes from we still call the
sympathetic nervous system but we don't
think of it the way they did and that's
because of Thomas Willis Thomas willow
said no it's not this this mysterious
connection there's this this mystical
Union
it's a network of nerves and he could
trace them and show how these different
organs were connected both to to each
other and then to the brain and so that
meant that you could also cure people by
by thinking of them as being a brain and
a nervous system with chemical spirits
not some sort of mystical spirits in
them but the real chemical particles
that you could manipulate so for example
epilepsy was not being seized by a demon
it wasn't even an excess of some sort of
one of the humors it was explosions that
were out of control that were that were
happening at the wrong time in the wrong
place and creating unwanted seizures a
person is melancholy not because they
have too much melancholy in them Willis
would say there is no such thing as
melancholy as black bile as a substance
there's something going on chemically in
the body and so if we can alter it we
can cure melancholy so I'd argue that
you know if you're looking for where
Prozac and all that comes from it comes
from here
now obviously Thomas Willis you know he
didn't know about Prozac I mean his
unfortunately his medical treatments
were pretty awful even after he made all
these breakthroughs he still led a lot
of blood and he believed that you should
use a sort of a steel syrup to cure
people of melancholy and in some cases
he would come up with very modern
sounding explanations that when you
think about it really very weren't very
modern at all so hysteria for example it
used to be believed as I said that the
womb would rise up so traditional
doctors would put a belt around the body
to keep the wound down now
when Thomas Willis would treat hysteria
he sometimes would put a belt around
people's body but what he said was that
it was taming these animal spirits
it was controlling their movement around
through the nervous system so so same
cure different rationale and I think
that that among other things is an
interesting thing to think about in
terms of how people today go about
dealing with with mental disorders and
neurological disorders Thomas Willis was
incredibly influential and not just in
these particular ways I was talking
about yeah he he really sort of made the
the brain the serve agreed-upon thing I
mean everyone very quickly came to say
well yeah the brain is this and the
ventricles just started to become very
unimportant you know for us you know
death equals brain death that kind of
central nests of the brain is thanks to
Willis and and to sort of illustrate
just how agreed on the brain became I
like to show this picture this is from
the 1700s
it's a cartoon by by the artist william
Hogarth attacking Methodists Methodists
at the time were basically considered
insane fanatics by the ruling class so
here you have an illustration of a
Methodist Church and the congregation is
swooning you have the minister dangling
a witch in his hand to try to scare
people and make them hysterical there
are all sorts of symbols of Hogarth's
contempt for these Methodists what's
really interesting for me is what's down
in the lower right hand corner and I'll
just zoom in here what it is it's a
brain there's no little tag saying this
is a brain he doesn't need to put a tag
on because everyone knows what it is
everyone's agreed on what it is and it
really and it has the same position as
Christopher Wren's brain which shows you
how influential it was the difference
though is that there's a little
thermometer stuck in it and so this is
sort of this is reading the the
the the fanaticism of these Methodists
and you have this scale going from from
despair to agony to lust to madness
so the Methodists are up to madness now
this is this was a you know the
thermometer of course was a very much a
scientific revolution of reason over
fanaticism and so hogarth felt totally
totally correct in in showing this thing
which gives you a sense of what the
brain had come to represent I mean here
the question becomes would you call a
Methodist insane now obviously we would
not you would not go out and do a study
of Methodists to see what was wrong with
their brain why is it that we don't do
that now and they might do that then
it's a very complicated issue and one
that's worth thinking about we have to
be careful about what we read into the
brain when we look at the the image of
the brain what do we see there and
Thomas Willis is a great lesson in this
he made huge mistakes as well as great
insights so for example he believed like
everyone else you know every other
member of the elite in England that that
peasants were [ __ ] they wouldn't use
that word but they would say that they
were fools or idiots that they really
couldn't understand the theology or
philosophy or anything like that and
they and so Thomas Willis would cut open
people's brains in order to understand
why this fact was why it was that that
peasants were idiots and so he cut open
this is actually an illustration by
Christopher Wren of the brain of a boy
that Willis described was a fool from
birth and after he died well let's cut
him open and tried to look for signs of
why was that that people were stupid and
he came up with lots of elaborate
explanations about how the brain had a
distorted shape or or that it was
the spirits had a difficult time cutting
paths through through the brain which
made perfect sense to him but but
obviously not to us so so I think that
that that that this this remarkable time
in history has lots of lessons to teach
us and you know today we're looking at a
really so remarkable kind of mirroring
of what was happening in Thomas Willis's
time so instead of knives and injections
people are using fMRI scanners but we
still have to be on our guard because we
shouldn't be reading images reading into
these images what we want to see these
studies are continuing to redefine what
was called the soul in many ways and in
many ways in which we don't yet
understand thanks very much
every bit of marvelous actually the
c-span is kindly taping this and so they
had asked me if you could give you give
you a question at the microphone right
behind you this is very formal huh well
thank you very much for a very uh
erudite and certainly entertaining talk
and accurate in the last four hundred
years the history of neurology but I
think you really sure change the
ancients badly and let me tell you why
people should know I teach history
medicine in this institution so allow me
to say a few comments people ought to
know that from ancient times from the
time of classical Greece many people
thought that the brain was the most
important organ in the body it was not
just from the 1600 so on and they knew
it's amazing that a lesion the right
side of the brain causes paralysis on
the left side they knew about the DQ
session of these fibers in the lower
encephalo and I think more important of
all you emitted Hippocrates I mean to
have a man who in 400 more or less BC is
going to write the following men ought
to know that it's in the brain and the
brain alone that we have our fears our
pleasures what we like what we dislike
through it we here we see we feel that's
very very important and then he goes on
to say the brain is the most important
organ of the body and then last but not
least that wonderful statement in the
sacred disease where he says and
therefore I assert that the brain is the
interpreter of consciousness I don't
think any neurophysiologists today at
the beginning early 21st century could
put it better so I would like to make
those comments I hope you forgive me for
being Frank but that's absolutely true
and you know that I mean I'm sure
yes no III agree completely that that
should be mentioned that yes that that
there were that that there were amazing
discoveries in ancient Greece and and
and many things that we can look upon
now as being brilliant insights into
into the working of the brain and I do
do talk about that more at length in the
book so but a couple things to point out
is one is that unfortunately a lot of as
unfortunately a lot of that was lost in
terms of people's understanding in
Europe that much of that was not
appreciated or followed up on so the
beautiful experiments that Galen did did
not lead to an experimental science of
the nervous system it led to a sort of a
very rigid doctrine in in Europe for
centuries and and the other thing is
that in some cases it's easy to read in
I I would argue that in some cases it's
tempting to read in to some of these
statements more than what is there in
the sense of for example there there was
a whole sense of there being Numa the
this serves the Greek word for spirit
which is very different from from what
we understand and and so and and that
was really sort of the central kind of
principle of how what they would call
the brain worked and and and sometimes
the connections are not quite quite
there but but your your basic point I
completely agree with and and as I say I
talk about more in my book yes
well I I also want to thank you for
talking about are bringing to people's
attention the accomplishments of Willis
was one of my personal heroes but but I
think that the story is very incomplete
without at least mention of the two
other great figures of that moment which
are Sydenham and Locke and in fact you
mentioned the beginning that will is
perhaps unjustly has gone into eclipse
but the reason he went
is mainly because of the rise of
empiricism and it shouldn't be mentioned
that Locke was both the student of
Willis and of Sydenham and he switched
his allegiance from Willis to Sydenham
precisely because Sydenham who was
considered the father of modern clinical
medicine focused on the living and on
the observational powers rather than on
this attempt of Lewis's to link alchemy
and theory and religious concepts with
you know the physical body and I think
that prevents if one reads Willis's
notes of his clinical experiences you
know he kept notes of his on his
patients it's amazing as you pointed out
how little of his findings in the
laboratory and in his chemical lab in
his chemical experiments actually
translated into practice in fact the
opposite as you mentioned what hysteria
which is pretty also you should mention
that he was also the first discoverer of
diabetes for example so it wasn't just
brained but my point is that it was
represents a kind of a blending of a
scientific and clinical exploration
which has now become the model for the
modern academic clinician which we now
have a problem with also but which you
shouldn't you know mentioned the the
concept of science versus clinical
practice but but suddenly him simply
told locke when he came to him after
having been a student of Willis at
Oxford as you mentioned he was this
professor of neurology at Oxford and in
fact the only lecture is available to us
from Willis his time were through lots
lakhs as a medical student taking these
classes what I'm making the point now is
that Locke who of course became one of
the great philosophers of of empiricism
and humanism learned those lessons not
from Willis but from Sidney ahem and
when Sidney Hamm first saw a lot as a
medical student and Locke wanted to do
an apprenticeship with him he said the
first thing you have to forget is these
anatomist s-- in at Oxford who only
studied the dead we study the living and
if you read the dictionaries of
scientific descriptions over the seven
in 18th century you will find will as
being you know demonized for for
misleading the world into the wrong
pathway until of course the modern era
so I just wanted to make that statement
totally appreciate your your your your
spotlight on Willis but Willis cannot be
seen in isolation from the rest of it
well just just add thank you very much
for your comments I mean and just as I
had in my book I talk more about sort of
the understanding of the brain in the
ancient world my second or last chapter
in the book is all about John Locke and
inside him I go into a lot of detail
about that because it is quite
remarkable that you know that Thomas
Willis is so forgotten I mean I I went
to Westminster Abbey where he's buried
and you can go to his stone which has
been fixed up by some neurologists who
were concerned that it gotten old and
cracked and I was just sort of standing
there and I just sort of watching people
going by and nobody even stopped once
they didn't even slow down they were
just on their way to see Darwin or
Newton or all these other people and and
I think John Locke is in large part to
blame for that you're right because he
John Locke a student of Willis's was one
of the architects of the Enlightenment
and a lot of what he said was we have to
be totally empirical and and purely
observational and you know when I talk
about the mind I'm only gonna talk about
ideas I'm not going to talk about where
and the brain this all takes place
what's ironic though and I try to point
out in the book is that John Locke sorta
took it as a given that the brain worked
in the way that Willa said it did he
just said well you know we all agree on
that I'm not gonna get any more detail
about that but then that becomes sort of
a fundamental foundation on which he
then builds all of his own philosophy so
even as Thomas Willis gets sucked under
in the tides of history his ideas really
live on
so thank you very much and please I
don't think this is on but in any case
thank you very much I'm I please forgive
me if I've missed anything
um I I didn't hear all of your talk but
I didn't notice that dominant themes in
your history and include a very male
centered as well as a very aristocratic
sense of the development of the science
and I'm very concerned insofar as I
understand and I receive as a medical
student a lot of the culture of
neurobiology as being a fundamentally
about control and so I'm concerned that
this doctrine of control and greater
control over ourselves and over our
bodies has arisen from what is
predominately a male centered as well as
aristocratic lineage and I'm wondering
if you could comment upon that or
perhaps to speak to a more diverse
origin of this history and see or
comments perhaps upon the our modern
perception of science and how it plays
upon that the question in case you
weren't able to hear was that just
commenting and how this is a very sort
of controlled oriented aristocratic
based or since a ruling class based kind
of birth of this science and male yes
and you know that that's all true and
that's all it's all sort of a you know
the science is a product is the birth of
the science is a product of its time and
in this time women do not go to the
university women do not have the
opportunity to do these things and so
that and and the Scientific Revolution
was all about control we will control
the world we will control the earth we
will control our bodies we will control
everything and this is also a time of
course when
Britain in particulars becoming a great
Empire we're gonna control our colonies
we're going to control our slaves we're
going to do all of this scientifically
for you know for great profit and so
they're all of these ideas are all kind
of there at the beginning and some of
it's not you know some of the aspects of
that are not pretty and and may may be
in need of supervision I mean another
part of the book that I wasn't able to
talk about addresses your question which
is there was a fascinating exchange that
Thomas Willis had with one patient of
his name and Conway it was a wonderful
figure she was a great philosopher in
her own right but but you know had no
formal education she went on to
influence Leibniz and other philosophers
and she was a patient of Willis's she
had these horrible migraine headaches
that he observed and tried to treat
couldn't help her and these headaches
actually helped her to sort of come up
with an alternate philosophy of her own
she did not divide the world into just
the way Descartes might into soul and so
dead matter she believed that everything
was sold just different degrees of soul
and and so and it was a completely
different way of understanding the body
and the mind and the world and you know
she's a her this wonderful point she
made in a book she wrote which was long
forgotten unfortunately was them you
know essentially the point she was
making is if if the soul is so distinct
from the body in the world and you know
why do I have these horrible headaches
why do I have to experience them there
there's there's more of a connection
there and so I just find it fascinating
that Thomas Willis the founder of a
certain kind of
a look way of looking at the brain in
the mind and an con we actually spend a
lot of time together as dr. impatient
thanks so much